the wrong for this uh-huh Barry's mother
though the beauty treatments continue
for miss cardi B Whitehead Oh horn car D
getting some sort of facial on her
Instagram story and I for one love that
she's always honest about what she's
doing the new post comes after she
admitted to getting a liposuction why
was that important for you to share it
was important to me to share you know
what a lot of people was just like
egging me on to do it even so I was
going to do it because I really want to
explain to people how hard is the
process I feel like a lot of people look
at girls on Instagram and think like oh
they got the lipo done and it was so
easy and this is such a long hard
process it's almost like the same
process as after you give birth to a
baby and you see your body change and
snapping it back is the same wave and
exclusively 1218 this I just got my
boobs redone did you really yes are you
in pain at all uh no no no yeah and
feeling good yes my daughter she they
know Kerdi actually had to pull out of a
string of her shows on account of
healing from her recent surgery but that
means more time at home with her
daughter they'll wake up in the morning
and like she's in my bed and I just want
to cut her but nothing in this way and
when it comes to culture well we know
she spares no expense
earlier this week she posted then
deleted that she dropped eighty thousand
dollars on her 10 month old and now we
have video culture wearing her new bling
[Applause]
but nothing in this world I like more
than checks cardi also shared these
snaps indulging in some barbecue and
sharing her new perfume obsession I'll
be spraying our [ __ ] all summer with
this wait hold on that's Beyonce on that
shirt I'll be spraying our [ __ ] all
summer with this anyone that you want to
collaborate with I feel like a Beyonce
collaboration of course we don't want
that
you don't what I'm saying you'd be down
for it though still waiting on that
Beyonce collab but what I will say is
cardi never fails to entertain what do
you guys love most about cardi though
let us know and of course make sure you
subscribe to all things et for all the
latest until next time I'm Katie Krauss
and bye for now
[Music]